Okay.
We were discussing the rise of the Polis and I was,
uh,
into the subject of the way the Greeks thought about the significance and the
function of the Polis,
which is really critical.
I believe in distinguishing between the Polis ASPEC a example of a city,
state and other cities,
states in history.
It's the notion of what the function of that state is.
I think that is most striking.
I,
um,
I was about to tell you last time about the poet Hesiod who lived in a little
town,
uh,
and be Osha to the north of Attica.
Uh,
he describes himself as a farmer and in the works and days he talks about the
quarrel he had with his brother and how he was mistreated in his opinion.
When his brother bribed the,
uh,
the barons,
the Basti lace in his area of,
uh,
and cheated him of his birthright.
And,
uh,
he quotes a kind of a fable.
He says he is a fool.
I'm sorry.
It tells us this fable of the Hawk and the Nightingale,
which illustrates really the doctrine of might over right.
And the Hawk says he is a fool who tries to match his strength with the stronger
he will lose the battle and with the shame will be heard also.
So don't try to fight against stronger people is what he says.
Uh,
he,
she,
it says this is the wrong doctrine.
It is better.
He says,
to go by the path leading to justice for when justice is outraged.
And by the way,
justice here is personified in the form of the goddess called decade.
She follows perforce weeping to the Polis and the gatherings of people.
She puts a dark mist upon her and brings a curse upon all those who drive her
out,
who deal in her and twist her in dealing.
And he speaks about the word Polis more than once.
In the same general context,
he draws a contrast between the men who give just decisions to strangers and to
natives and who do not depart from what is just,
and those who practice violence and cruel deeds.
In the case of the former,
the polis flourishes and its people prosper.
Peace reigns over their land and Zeus keeps them free of wars.
They don't suffer famines or disasters.
Their flocks have thick wool.
Their wives bear them children.
So fruitful is their land that they are spared the evil necessity of traveling
on ships.
And there you have,
uh,
an interesting point about the Greeks he's using is not alone in saying for
God's sake,
try not to take a voyage at sea because your chances of coming back or really
bad,
which was the reality to a degree,
it's a very strange thing because the Greeks turned out to be an enormously
active seafaring people with tremendous fear of the sea.
I think that those things are connected.
But what about those who don't follow the path of righteousness,
of justice,
of decay?
Zeus orders severe punishments for them.
Often even a whole Polis is paid punishment for one bad man.
His people are troubled by disasters,
plagues,
famines.
The men die.
The women are barren.
At another time,
Zeus destroys the y camped army of people or wrecks their city with its walls or
their ships on the open water.
Well,
one thing that emerges from these lines and Hesiod is that poke,
the policy's already there.
There was no way to talk about what he's talking about in the kinds of
settlements that existed before the invention of the Polis.
And that I think is worth mentioning if our date for him,
which is very problematical,
but if it's right roughly then by certainly by 700 BC,
there are people who know what police are,
police exist.
But beyond that there is the fact that for the Greeks that early and always by
the way it remains.
So the notion of,
uh,
justice is directly connected with the Poles.
The only place where justice exists or can exist is in a polis.
The only way you can lead a good life is if you live in a polis.
And when you do live in a Polis,
of course you will have to behave justly because,
and this is tremendously important.
Your behavior doesn't affect just you and your family.
It involves the entire community.
Remember,
even one bad man can ruin a pose.
That is a very strong statement about the priority of community.
And it's very different from the values that we knew we saw in the Iliad and the
Odyssey.
You cannot imagine.
It seems to me in the world that he see a describes Achilles or anybody else
saying,
well you insulted me and I'm not going to fight anymore for my poles.
That would have been inconceivable in this world now so we're on at this given
this information we are on to the problem.
That will be a problem for the Greek Polis for the rest of it's history and it's
really a problem to this very day for all people who live in some sort of a
civilized community,
how to reconcile the interests and desires and wellbeing of the individual and
his immediate family.
With those of the community at large,
they may seem and probably might even be said to be different and antagonistic
at some point and when they are,
what should you do for the Greeks?
The answer was pretty clear hereafter one ought to be interested and to take
action in behalf of the Polis and we'll be seeing this kind of argument and
people presenting positions about it going on into the future,
but to positions nobody is going to be very comfortable if comfortable at all.
It would be a very odd ball position to take for the rest of Greek history.
No,
the right thing to do is to take care of yourself and the hell with the polls.
That's not what you're going to hear.
What you're going to hear is to the contrary.
A little bit later when we get to talking about Sparta,
you'll see a beautiful example of that in the form of a,
the poems of Tortillas who was a poet in Sparta whose poetry became so central
to their way of thinking and living that they were used as marching songs for
the Spartan Army as they walked and they make the same point.
But I'll come back to that.
Now here's another document that you want to be aware of that gives you some
idea of what the Greeks fairly early thought the Polis was for and about.
And what's the relationship between individual and Polis was in this case I'm
talking about,
uh,
Hurghada Titus who very early in his history,
speaks about a tell us the story really of,
um,
his visit to Lydia to the land of the great tyrant creases who is also the
richest man in the world.
It's not clear that this event ever really took place,
but it's really not very important because what [inaudible] is doing is telling
how he,
I think and how the Greek in general viewed the questions at issue.
So on goes to visit creases.
Creases asks so long to tell him who is the happiest,
the most fortunate.
Both of those things contained in this and the words he uses that he had ever
seen so on was now a man of full years.
He was a man of greatly respect that he turns out to be one of the seven sages
that the ancient Greeks selected for the wisest men,
whoever war.
So if,
uh,
it would be interesting to know what he thought about that.
Um,
of course,
creases had shown his great wealth already to,
uh,
so long.
And in my view,
he put the question this way.
So long as he looked around at his fabulous wealth and great,
good fortune,
he said,
who,
who do you think is the happiest,
most fortunate man you ever knew him?
And you know what the answer was that he expected.
So on answered,
tell us of Athens.
I bet you never heard of telus of Athens.
Neither had creases.
Neither had anybody else outside of Athens.
Creases was astonished.
And he asks Solon why?
Why did he select telus?
And here's what her,
this says first because his city was flourishing.
That is Polis.
That's the word in Greek,
was flourishing in his time.
And he himself had sons,
both beautiful and good.
The words in Greek are Carlos Agathos for the singular cowboy cowgirl toy.
And it's a kind of a formula.
It means a gentlemen.
It means the best kind of person.
If a person is a coloscopy I thoughts it means he is good to look at.
And his soul is excellent.
All that you could expect of a person.
So he had a,
uh,
um,
two.
He had sons,
beautiful and good,
and he lived to see children born to each of them.
And these children all grew up and further because after a life spent in what
our people look upon as comfort,
his end was surpassingly glorious and a battle between the Athenians and their
neighbors near elusive.
He came to the assistance of his countrymen,
routed the foe,
and died upon the field.
Most gallantly,
the Athenians gave him a public funeral on the spot.
Gray fell and paid him the highest honors.
So to summarize,
the happiest,
the most fortunate man that so on ever knew was a dead Athenian that nobody ever
heard of.
Why?
What does this say,
right?
We see in this passage something that reveals so much about what the Greek
values were,
and you'll see how closely they were tied up with the Polis and the primacy of
the Polis in their lives.
Well,
well,
why?
Why are things good?
Well,
his city,
his Polis was doing well.
A man who was living in a Polish not doing well.
How can he be happy?
There's just no way.
Secondly,
sons.
Now this has to do with the Greek idea about immortality and mortality since the
Greeks really didn't believe in personal immortality.
How do you find what everybody wants in mortality?
One way is through your family and it's sons who carry forward the family name,
so to speak.
So if you have sons and they are healthy and they do well and they have
children,
that means your name will be carried into the future,
your memory will persist.
And that is one form of immortality.
And then of course the greatest form of immortality.
And think of it when you compare it with what was the form of immortality
available to Achilles and his fellow heroes.
You fought for your Polis and when you died fighting no glue for your Polis,
you will be.
And we're then you,
you were uh,
honored extraordinarily by that Polis.
And what everybody knew then was that you are memory with last thereafter,
so long as your polis lasted.
And the proof of it is that Herata it is,
knows that story and is telling it as will other storytellers.
And in fact it worked.
Here we are talking about,
tell us all these many years later thanks to her Auditas but the point is that
this form of immortality is available to tell us because of his place in the
polls,
because of the deeds he does for the Polis.
And that is the greatest possible pay off.
And there you see something that is,
you know,
I've been making the case that a polos is a different thing from any other city
state.
I'm not aware that any other culture that had city states had ideas of this con
that,
uh,
help make,
explain why one was associated with it and cared about it.
And,
um,
the final document I want to use to make the point here comes from precisely the
poems of solar as we shall see later.
So long will be a very important political figure in Athens and at a critical
moment in Athenian history.
And the Athenians will give him the honor and the responsibility of being the
sole public official and to draw up a new constitution,
the laws for Athens enormously important job.
Um,
and in the course of doing that and in the course of defending himself against
the tax after he had done it,
he wrote but really amount to political pamphlets to defend his actions and to
set forth the ideas that lay under his,
um,
uh,
the actual laws that he had put forward.
And,
um,
but as you may know in,
in writing the earliest kinds of writing among the Greeks anyway,
I think this is not a typical come,
not in the form of prose but in the form of poetry.
And that's because people are used to,
uh,
before they use writing,
they are used to remembering things through verse.
I don't know if this is true of you,
but it certainly is true of people in my generation,
the things that they taught us in school when they required us to remember
poetry,
no matter how we try,
we can't forget it.
And the stuff that we had,
remember that was in prose.
No matter how we try,
we can't remember it.
It's the rhythm.
Uh,
I bet even all of you can,
can remember songs that you have known all your life.
But not other things.
So it's a great mnemonic device,
but in any case,
that's why,
uh,
so lungs,
pamphlets are written in poetry and,
uh,
apparently in a really good poetry.
And so we have his very words here is a of a fragment from one of his poems.
So the public ruin invades the house of each citizen and the courtyard doors no
longer have strength to keep it away,
but it overlaps the lofty wall.
And though a man runs in and tries to hide it as chamber or closet,
it ferrets him out.
So my spirit dictates to me,
I must tell the Athenians how many evils a city suffers from bad government.
The Greek word for that is dish.
No,
Mia.
Uh,
and how good government a,
you know,
mia displays all neatness and order,
and many times she must put shackles on the breakers of laws.
I get this a,
you know,
mia levels,
rough places stops glut and greed takes the force from violence.
She drives up the growing flowers of despair.
As they grow,
she straightens out crooked judgments.
Remember those crooked judgments that he had complained about?
Well,
the Polis straightens out crooked judgments,
gives a given gentles the swollen ambitions and puts an end to act of divisional
strife.
She stills the gall of wary,
some hate and under her influence.
All life among mankind is harmonious and does well.
Wonderful.
Where do all these good things come from?
From God?
No,
they come from the Polis when its laws are good and therefore when the
government that it provides is uh,
you know,
mia rather than the opposite.
He is making a claim here,
which is a very strong,
powerful one,
but which was characteristic of the Greeks.
And I want you to take note of it.
Here he is giving them the law and the Polis that gives law.
It's not merely a negative thing the way I think modern ideas about law as for
instance,
represented in the American constitution,
uh,
are,
which is to say it's function is to prevent wrongdoing,
to punish wrongdoing.
It doesn't really,
well,
let me,
let me just say what the pull is claims to do here in Houma.
It claims actually to shape the character of mankind.
The Polis makes a good polis with following good laws,
makes its citizens better.
It not only defeats wrong,
but it creates right?
And it creates citizens who behave rightly.
This is tremendously important because every Greek state that we know about made
the claim that that's what it did,
no matter what its constitution was,
no matter how these different from one another,
the idea was that the state has to make good men and that for a city to be good,
the men must be good.
Um,
this is very different as if you think about the,
the American idea as an example of the modern way of thinking about these
things.
And the notion is a,
we,
we can't do anything.
The laws that can't do anything about making people better or worse,
it takes them as they are and then it deals with them accordingly.
But for the ancient Greeks,
that was not enough.
You could not,
uh,
an excuse me.
If you even think about the founding fathers,
Madison,
uh,
federalist 10,
based upon the principle that you,
you can expect that men will do wrong things and that a good constitution has,
uh,
the role of balancing the wrongs off against each other so as to produce the
closest approximation possible to justice.
You can only do that by balancing competitive desires that can be thought of as
evil faction was what they were talking about.
And everybody thought faction was bad,
but it was inevitable you couldn't get rid of factioned by saying to men,
it's not good to be factious.
You should think of the whole community at all times.
That's not what the American constitution is about.
But it was what the Greek constitutions were about.
A Polis ought to make men like that.
And in fact,
there's a great revolution in the political theory presented by the American
constitution in that it's not the first thing to do it,
but it was the first one that was really applied in turning away,
rejecting the possibility that a constitution could make men better.
It accepted the premise that men were what they were.
And that the state had to control that by various devices.
So it's very important to see how different from that the Greek idea was and
what an enormous responsibility the polis was supposed to have.
And of course with that there had to be an enormous amount of support for the
state by the citizens.
That's another thing I want to emphasize before I leave this subject.
The word citizen,
we should not take that for granted.
By the way,
in Greek,
the word citizen is pull,
leap tastes derives from Polis.
He somebody who lives in a Polis,
he's he's citizen.
Well,
there never was a citizen in the world before the Polis.
There were only subjects,
people who are subject either to a god or to the king or to representative that
God or to achieve tin or however.
But somebody in a sense owns them all.
But nobody owns a citizen.
And this is something brand new in the world and we shall see how it crops up in
different forms and how it shapes the course of Greek history.
Well,
this whole business presents the problem I mentioned a moment ago.
All of us have this natural selfishness.
When we are born.
We all seek our own interests and soon we join up with their family.
We want the families interest up to a point.
Uh,
and how is this fit together with the needs of the community at large?
A problem the Greeks always wrestled with,
but when you get down to the fifth century,
and indeed the latter part of the fifth century,
there is a marvelous document that you will be reading a into cities is the
famous funeral oration of Pericles is delivered in the winter of four 31 30 BC
where one of the,
in my judgement,
one of the great things about [inaudible] was that he had given a great deal of
thought to this problem and presented the best he could think of would for
solving that problem,
which was to claim that the individuals highest needs and greatest personal and
family goals could be met only through the Polis that his wellbeing was tied up
in extra capably with the wellbeing of the pause.
Now you know,
you don't have to buy that.
And individuals undoubtedly found a strain too much from time to time.
But what's interesting is rather the ideal,
the claim,
the theory,
you cannot truly achieve what you want and need as a human being without being
an active and loyal citizens of this great community which you need to achieve
what you want in life.
It is a claim already and as you've seen in Aristotle towards the end of the
history of the Free Polis,
it is something necessary for mankind.
It is the center of his life and it explains the Greeks devotion to the
independence,
to the autonomy of the pose and their desire to beautify it and make it as great
as it could possibly be.
All of that sounds very nice and it certainly had very nice aspects to it,
but there was of course a downside to it as well,
which is every Polis wants it to be great and it being Greeks,
they wanted it to be greater than the neighbors and sometimes that involves
conflict and it often among the Greeks did involve war.
Now the Greeks,
we're not unique in history and constantly being had war.
That is if you just examine the history of the human race.
So soon as they were sufficiently organized to wage war,
they began doing it all the time.
But it is true that the life of the Greek world was much more filled with war
throughout the history of the Poles.
Then other civilizations,
because other civilizations after a time had one great power that was able to
dominate the entire region.
Egypt being the best example so that no longer was war possible.
But the flip side of that is there was also another thing that was impossible
freedom and in Greece you have a lot of war and you have a lot of freedom and
all of that is tied up I think very much with the development of this very
special thing called the pulse.
Now let's take a look at other aspects of the Polis,
not ideas,
but rather how it functioned,
how it,
how it's functioned and how that helped to shape the characteristics that it
showed in its full blown period.
That is to say the classical period.
I want to talk about
it.
We're really sort of three things that come together.
One of them is how the Greeks in the,
in the late dark ages and on into the period in which the polos emerges,
made their living.
And the second has to do with how they fought.
And um,
uh,
what's my thing was my third,
there is a third one.
Oh yes.
And the third is that knocked.
These are not necessarily in the same in any particular order and also how they
were governed or rather how they govern themselves.
All of these three,
three things,
uh,
on my judgment are necessary to understand how the Polis came into being,
how it came to be,
what it was and how it came to,
uh,
fulfill and believe in these ideas that I have just been telling you about.
And I should say at once that this is now a very controversial subject.
Uh,
let me just back up a second.
In a way,
we're a,
along the way,
I'm attempting to also to answer the question that people always ask me when
they understand that I'm a historian about grease and if they have any interest
in this subject.
And he said,
yeah,
the Greeks were terrific.
They achieved wonderful things.
Ebay were miracle,
golden age and all that.
But tell me how did that happen?
Why did they do that?
But why them and not somebody else?
And until I came upon a brilliant solution that an another scholar presents to
us,
all I could do was tell jokes.
Uh,
I remember way before you guys were born,
there was a TV show run by Sid Caesar and one of the characters that repeatedly
showed up on this thing was kind of a comic German Austrian professor of
seemingly seemingly everything.
And then the call Rhino would interview him,
uh,
to,
on the topic that was allegedly the topic of the day.
And on the one I remember best was he was a great aeronautical expert.
And here he was landing briefly.
He was being interviewed by Carl Reiner,
ask him questions and in his comic German accent,
uh,
giving silly answers,
but finally,
um,
kindness as well.
Thank you.
Preventative.
That's all very wonderful.
But you know,
our audience would really like,
it seems like a simple question,
but it's awfully hard to understand how can a great big,
enormous heavy thing like this airplane get off the ground and he's an artist of
that I simpler question.
It's not difficult to answer.
I mean,
you know,
the beings go the Ale,
Yvonne's and then the border Aandra engine and it's a miracle how it gets up
there.
And that is the way I used to explain the Greeks because I had no better idea.
I could bumble around about geography and this and that,
but nothing.
Then there came a great voice from the West.
Victor Davis Hanson,
who was a professor at
Fresno State,
California,
um,
sought about this and he brought to it in addition to extraordinary intelligence
and a remarkably good knowledge of Greek and the Greeks,
something,
a magical additional elements.
And that was the fact that he was a farmer and he was,
I think in the fifth generation that had farmed the same piece of farmland in
California,
in the Central Valley of California,
uh,
ever since the 19th century.
And what that climate by the way,
and that whole scene is very similar to the Mediterranean kind of a climate that
the,
uh,
Greek,
farmers we're engaged in.
And so that it had potentially Hanson thought and I think he was right,
a proper analogous possibilities.
And,
uh,
he came to the conclusion that much could be learned about the development of
the Polis if one looked at the business of how one farms and these kinds of
environments.
And I think that turns out to be a great key to understanding what's happening.
And it's everything you hear from me on this subject,
I learned from Hanson.
It is needless to say,
being a bright,
brilliant idea that one guy thought of it has been assaulted on all sides and
there is plenty of controversy about it.
Uh,
you start with the dark ages and there was general agreement.
I think that the population of Greece had become much smaller than it had been
in the Mycenaean period.
And that from the standpoint of the population,
it could sustain.
It was underpopulated.
And if you start with a look at what was the way in which the land was worked
for the purposes of feeding the population,
it would be okay to take a look at the Homeric poems as some kind of evidence to
help us out.
And Hanson focused on this,
what was really obviously the unit that mattered in the,
in the world of homer,
the call it the family or,
but the Greek word is oil costs.
Oh,
I k o s.
And it really means it means household,
but it comes to mean the land that the family works,
the family itself.
And what does it look like?
Well,
in the Odyssey there is a very fine example of the,
uh,
of such a place in the form of the,
the oil costs of king layer tease the father of Odysseus who somehow was still
alive when Odysseus is king,
but he is in retirement.
And there he is.
We see him nobleman that he is former king,
that he is working the soil and how he does this is very illuminating what you
have.
Uh,
he,
because he is clearly according to Hanson involved in the period after the
transition away from an earlier style,
but the earliest style pictures rather large estates by Greek standards with
rating warrior groups going out to make a what seal,
what they can.
They are engaged in raising livestock,
which in in Greece is more likely to be sheep and goats,
then cattle.
Uh,
but also breeding horses,
which are the,
the thing that is very important for the aristocracy for carrying on warfare.
That's lil flip back a step beyond that to Mycenaean civilization for the
purpose of noting the great contrast,
a great change.
Remember liked in the ancient near east and kingdoms.
Collectivized agriculture control from the center.
The individuals who carry out the farming or the grazing,
they are don't,
they are not permitted individual initiative.
They are control.
This civilization like these other ancient Mediterranean kingdoms were rather
advanced.
They knew how to cultivate the grape to make excellent wine.
They knew how to cultivate a olives to be able to make superboy olive oil and
how to process them to produce the result.
They were engaged in our board culture.
They had fruit trees that produced very well.
It was a civilization that was rather advanced in terms of its agricultural
skill.
They knew the techniques for grafting and improving and domesticating species of
grapes and all of us particularly,
you know,
you can't go out there and just plant these things and what comes out is
inedible,
a unusable until you finally inter,
uh,
what's the word I want you have to generate
when you get,
when you mix two agricultural thing,
Greg,
you have to have the grant,
but what do you get?
Hybrids and in order to improve the category of what you're doing,
well,
they could do all that.
And that's the knowledge that was a in the palace that allow the kings in his
people to send out messages,
orders to everybody to do what they did.
Now when the palace civilization collapses,
the whole system collapses.
There is that explains in large part why there was such a decline in population.
Why the dark ages was so dark.
Lots of poverty,
lots of starvation.
But also as I suggested when I spoke to this earlier,
also the freedom,
if you could make it to learn and also to grow stronger.
Now it's sometime in that period of the dark ages and Hanson would suggest,
I think probably around the eighth century is the greatest transition.
Somehow the oil costs obtains a chunk of land that is understood to belong to
it.
The Greek word for that is a clay Ross.
He Ros.
And what happens is now the family knows that it has this land.
It has it now,
it will have it next year.
The family will be,
we will be able to pass it on from father to son so that he can inherit it.
And that changes everything.
That kind of stability gives promise and is a basis for making every kind of
necessary investment in the soil that you are working in order to,
uh,
make it better and more profitable for you.
And it's worth it because you'll be you and your children will be there to
collect it.
As Hanson says,
thus arose to Clara's or the idea of a privately held plot attached not to any
one person but rather in perpetuity to a single farm family or oil costs.
And as Hanson points out,
look at the difference between this and previous ways of working the soil.
People either rented the land from a large land owner or they were hired help
who got nothing except a salary or a piece of what they did.
Surfs who are compelled to work the land or in some places even slaves.
Well,
they have no incentive.
Put aside the question,
even if capacity to invest capital for the purpose of uh,
improving the size and quality of their crops,
their trees,
their vines,
they would not be willing to take the risk,
uh,
without clear title to the land.
That is the critical thing.
Once they haven't and they plant permanent crops,
that changes the whole basis of society and the values and the attitudes that go
with it.
In short,
according to Hanson,
it is the invention of the family farm.
That is the critical moment in this very,
very important moment in the history of the human race and there's certainly is
no example of it that I know of apart from Greece when it happens right about
this period.
You can imagine that if this can only happen gradually,
none of this happens overnight.
But if you think of the time span about 900 to 700 BC,
that is when these changes are taking place.
I would have guessed at an increasing pace as you go further down the road and
then what happens is the population grows and for this the archeological
evidence is very strong.
There are getting to be more and more people living on the land of Greece.
What do they do?
One of the problems that produces is the more people you have up to a point,
that's good.
There are more people who can work to increase the uh,
PR,
the production,
but beyond that point there were more people to feed then the production can
produce and that leads to a desire for expansion of the land available for
cultivation.
Now,
there are a couple of ways that can go.
One that was certainly important,
and again this was something that Hanson emphasizes is what he calls internal
colonization.
It means you know the way these things work.
When you are engaged in agriculture,
it's natural go first to that soil,
to that patch of land,
which is known to be likely to produce the best land,
the most fertile,
the most best product,
the most fertile land there is.
So that's where they start.
But now when you need more,
you can't just say,
I only want the best bottom land.
There is your move out to someplace that nobody bothered to farm before because
it wasn't profitable enough because you need more lan.
And so marginal land is brought into play with hard work and ingenuity.
And one of the things that Hanson emphasizes that so helpful,
you got to be a farmer to understand these things.
Not everything that you try works.
And the picture,
I think the picture he paints of farming et reminds us of the picture that the
homeowner pays of human condition as explained in the,
you know,
the pot,
the two,
the two jars of Zeus.
Most of the luck is bag.
It's hard to succeed and some combination of luck and skill and determination
and hard work,
uh,
all of that will decide which of these farmers will be successful and which will
not.
And that's an important thing to remember.
There'll be success and there will be failure.
Hanson says,
I'm recording him.
The real beginning in the west of individual property holding on a large scale
is what he is describing.
And he wants to emphasize.
Hanson himself has a farm that specializes in grapes for the purpose of
producing raisins.
I guess all the raisins in the world that produced near Fresno.
Isn't that right?
Curtis?
And uh,
he,
uh,
points out that the knowledge of how to do this,
of how to grow the kind of grapes who want viticulture and also our board
culture,
both of these are learned from Asia.
The Asians were ahead.
And the the end of the isolation of Greece made possible communication and it
allowed this kind of learning and so you got this picture of some people
learning how to do these things very,
very well.
Everything is farmed in a new way.
And let me just give you a picture of what this new farm that Hanson describes
is like there is intensive farming.
It's not extensive in the sense you know you just have to scatter your stuff
over wide fields.
The same thing over a great,
that's not what it is.
Every piece of that soil is necessary.
A lot of it can't produce the crop you would most like to grow.
So you find another crop that will grow there that can be useful.
That's that's the picture.
So you have varied crops among them.
These are the ones that are typical of a Mediterranean climate.
Everybody needs grain.
Bread is the staff of life as you have been rightly toll,
but so you try.
If you ha,
if you can grow grain on your land,
you grow it where you can,
it's not going to have to get it elsewhere.
Olives for the purposes that I mentioned to you the other day.
That is a very important one.
Um,
vegetables can be grown many times in places where you could never grow wheat or
a grain.
Um,
fruits from the trees.
What have I left out,
Curtis?
Anything we left out?
Anything that you,
any of the crops,
that's about it.
And those are the things that you do now.
Observe several things about them.
They together will make up everything you need to live.
All the food groups are represented there.
I have left out meat and fish of course,
neither of them very common in the uh,
in this part of the world.
But meat was common enough because there were sheep and their workouts,
even when,
uh,
beef would have been very hard to get.
But what you need to understand about the Greeks,
they don't eat a lot of meat.
Now you might say,
how come no fish?
I mean this surrounded by water.
Everywhere you look.
Well,
guess what?
Turns out fish don't live everywhere in the water and they don't live very much
around Greece.
It turns out,
I don't mean no fish,
but no sort of major schools of fish.
This is not the banks of Newfoundland and the Greeks don't eat fish but not a
lot.
So they're dying is a little bit of that.
There are some of their protein from that.
Uh,
then bread,
olive oil,
fruit,
vegetables,
cheese,
milk,
those kinds of things they can do
well.
Now,
one of the things farmers in history discovered is that it's very hard to do
well as a farmer and a big,
if you,
all you do is grow the crops because people normally don't use what you grow in
the form in which you grow it.
I'm thinking again of Grapes and Olives,
they made maybe mostly one olive oil.
And why?
So why do you do?
Well,
if you're a poor farmer,
you don't know what else to do.
You send it off to a middleman who does the turning of,
of uh,
the grapes and the olives into the liquids that are necessary and he takes a
good bit of the profit.
But these farmers didn't do that.
They acquired the equipment necessary grape,
uh,
and olive presses,
which allowed them to purify and to produce,
uh,
the final product and that made them more successful than they otherwise would
have been.
And also the,
another great thing that you have to be able to do if you're going to succeed as
a pharmacy,
you could be,
I have to have places to store what you produce so that you will have it for
next year when you need it.
And also if you have a surplus and that's a desirable thing to do,
you can sell it.
Probably in the early days,
this was largely a question of barter.
You could trade it in for those things that you didn't make yourself and needed.
But any case,
in any case,
it is a profit,
but it's no good if it's going to spoil.
And so it's important to realize the role of ceramics,
the they need to make storage jars that could be sealed very well and preserve
this stuff for a very long time.
And indeed they did that.
Another thing that you need to understand about these farms if you're going to
grasp their significance for the society that will come is that they are small,
really small.
Uh,
maybe a typical,
a farm you might imagine has maybe 10 acres that is a very small farm.
Some of them of course were bigger.
There was no regulation about it,
but we are talking not about the emergence of an agricultural aristocracy,
but we are talking about the emergence of a,
an agricultural community of small family farms.
And one of the things that comes with the development of this kind of
agriculture as the policies coming into being is slavery.
Now,
of course slavery is as old almost as the human race.
Uh,
and it certainly was already present in the world of Houma.
but it looks like in the dark ages there were very few slaves around.
Just because owning slaves is wealth.
You can't have slaves without wealth because you got to feed them.
That's the very least.
And no matter how wicked a master you are dead slaves on,
no good to you.
Chances are you had to pay something for them.
They are like a machine.
If he slave dies,
got to buy a new machine and while he's alive,
you've got to feed them.
So when you're talking about a very poor society,
not going to see much slavery.
But it is true that as the uh,
family farm I've been describing comes into being away,
is found to use slaves in a productive,
positive way,
positive from the standpoint of profits.
Um,
and the reason for that is if you are just engaged in a single crop farming,
well you're planted,
you take care of it and then when the time comes you reap it.
What do you do in between?
Well,
there's not much to do,
so you have to feed the slave all year round to work only a small part of the
time that's not very profitable.
But Hanson's farm is,
I like to think of it.
Uh,
there's work to do all year round because these different crops need attention
at different times and they need different kinds of attention and some of them
need all kinds of very hard work to keep them going so that there's plenty of
work to be done that is useful and profitable.
Therefore,
and you will produce enough profit to make it possible so that these small
farms,
you should imagine as typically having one or two slaves playing a part in this
experience.
And um,
the,
uh,
and if the funding,
I mean you should not imagine when I say slaves,
it just take out of your mind the plantations of the old south because when you
only have one or two slaves,
the master is what working right alongside them doing the exactly the same work
that they are doing and also instructing them and telling them what's what.
It's probably if you want to really understand this,
uh,
in a practical sense,
it's more as though these guys are hired hands mean.
They live around,
they live in the house,
they get fed,
preferably with everybody else.
They work with the master.
The difference being that they are slaves rather than a free men.
And uh,
and that's one of the funny things is that the,
the,
the emergence of this family farm gives rise to the Polis,
his character as a land in which there was a citizenry which is to say free men
ruled themselves.
So the Polis,
we'll see the,
the invention of freedom in this way.
And oddly enough,
it is a company by the growth of slavery.
At the same time,
both slavery and freedom come along at the same time in the Greek world.
One of the interesting,
uh,
documents we have is a fragmentary inscription from the island of chaos.
I think it's in the eighth century,
uh,
that Hanson points out as relevant here on it.
There is a little language and it's obvious,
it's talking about some kind of a town council.
This is the first time we have such a reference.
The Greek words are Boulay hey day.
Most of the Aa that is best translation I can come up with is the council for
the people.
It doesn't mean the council of the people necessarily that would suggest
something democratic.
It's probably more a oligarchic or aristocratic.
But the point is,
this is something we haven't heard of ever before.
There was clearly some kind of an official group that has some sort of political
role to play,
which is popular in its character.
It's the word de Moss that's at the root of day,
most ca and day most means the people,
all the people.
That's one of its meanings and I think it's the meaning that's relevant here.
And as Hanson point south,
only in early Greece did independent agrarians have free title to their land,
own slaves.
And ultimately out of this,
uh,
council that I told you about ultimately came to have control of their own
communities.
Uh,
although the political development came late in the process,
it did come as Hanson says,
the new farmer is not just a different kind of farming,
but a different kind of person.
He is a citizen in his political role.
He is a soldier but he is the soldier not in the pay or the higher of a King of
an aristocracy.
He is a citizen soldier who has participated in the decision that says it is
time to go to war and who will play an active role in making decisions about his
state's policy and behavior.
He is independent in a way that nobody who was not a king or an aristocrat and
the past has ever been a new kind of man.
Okay.
The backbone of the Polis as it emerges.
I don't want to overstate this.
There will still,
there is still an aristocracy made up of the old guys and they don't just
disappear and they will be a long stretch in which there will be some degree of
conflict between these new independent farmers and the old established
aristocracy and never does that aristocracy go away.
That's all.
I'm simply emphasizing what's new in the situation and it's very new indeed.
I might just say a little bit more of
Hansen as ax marvelous situation in which he's a scholar telling us about these,
these developments in the world of ancient agriculture and farming.
But he's also an active farmer and reacting to what happens to farmers today.
And he's written a book,
a wonderful book called fields without dreams,
which is the story of modern farming in America with,
it's also true of all of Western Europe,
uh,
which is to do pretty much with the abolition of farmers.
And I just don't think it's right for me to pass without mentioning the
significance of that.
Nobody knows anything about it.
Uh,
what percentage of Americans do you think worked on farms at the end of the 19th
century?
2060 you better believe it's 60,
70.
And the further back you go in American history,
the closer to 90 and 95% it gets.
That's the history of the world.
The whole human race has spent the bulk of its time farming.
Yeah.
What percentage of Americans are engaged in farming today?
Well,
the figure I saw last was a number too small to be mentioned.
I mean to say you just can't really say how much it is,
but all right,
2%.
Does anybody know a farmer?
Okay.
How,
how come?
Just by accident still still farming.
God bless him.
Is his son farming.
No kidding.
Where is this?
Fantastic.
That's a marvelous thing.
Please give him my greetings.
Um,
but it,
it's kind of a miracle.
I don't know any farmers.
Oh yeah,
I know Hanson but I didn't know him.
I wouldn't know any farmers.
So now I don't want to go too deeply into this if you're interested in this
subject,
get hold of his book.
But uh,
I think it's really what is inescapable is farmers are a sociological category
of people,
different from non farmers and all kinds of critical ways.
And it is just as a example of how,
uh,
this whole business has disappeared.
Nobody even thinks about it anymore.
If you were to say to me,
what do you think is the most important thing,
however you define thing that has changed the character of life in the United
States in the 20th century?
I would say the disappearance of farmers.
There are so many ways in which that has changed the world,
but I can't do justice to it,
but Hanson does.
So if you want to read fields without dreams,
you can ponder the significance of this great change.
Now,
I've talked to you essentially about the economic aspect of this a phenomenon
and I'd like to turn a next week.
Give me a second here.
I just want to find out where I am in this,
right?
These are all my proofs to tell you to support all the things that I've already
told you,
but I'm not going to bother approving it.
Take too long.
Uh,
well
I guess the next thing I might mention is in the area of politics,
if you look at the world of my Sini,
once again,
we've already seen this.
You have a despotism of some kind.
You have some kind of a Lord.
I mean a king if for lack of a better name,
Almanor who fundamentally rules and everybody is subject to him.
He has an aristocracy around them.
He has lot kind of helpers,
but he's the boss and that's what you see in the world everywhere else.
Uh,
after that,
if you examine as best we can,
the cities of the dark ages and ask what kind of government,
if you want to use that word with these communities,
have had,
you probably wouldn't do badly if you looked at the odyssey for the best clues
you could find.
If of course they won't be perfect.
You know,
this mixed character of the world of homer,
but still,
if you look at the world of Odysseus is home.
What's going on in um,
uh,
in Ithica there were some valuable clues.
There is somebody who in that world called a bus allows a busted loose,
I should say no.
Yeah,
busted lawyers,
right?
Who is a,
a single individual who was understood to be superior in some way for everybody
else.
However,
he's not very superior to everybody else.
He has all of these nobleman around him,
all of whom claim to be vacillates.
You Recall?
And what a fair way to put this with that.
This is largely an heiress to credit society.
That was our conclusion after we looked at the poems of homer.
And I think that's what continues even after the,
when that's the world that shows up after my senior people who had power by
virtue of their wealth,
by virtue of their personal,
uh,
physical strength,
maybe,
uh,
by virtue of their dissent.
Because people always have theories about individuals and their society.
I mean,
early societies who were born to the purple,
so to speak.
But whatever the criteria were,
and birth always was a critical criterion in the days of the aristocracies.
Uh,
you would have aristocracies who would have the,
uh,
practical,
the de facto control of things.
Well,
by definition and aristocracy is plural,
not singular.
So how do you make decisions in an aristocracy?
And the answer typically is a council,
I use the word council,
the Greek word is Boulay,
uh,
and not assembly,
which in Greek comes to be called Ekklesia.
Um,
because in that clay,
sia is understood to be a gathering of the entire adult male population.
And the Boulay is understood to be not a,
a gathering of the whole,
but rather a smaller group who has some degree of authority.
And I would have suggested that in the earliest days,
uh,
they had all the authority that mattered.
However,
it's interesting,
these Greek communities from earlier,
very early time seem to have been different from the Mycenaean kinds of things
by virtue of the fact that the men who fought in the army always seem to have
had to be consulted when it came to a question of fighting.
And so you always had an assembly,
even an error,
Socratic states,
but decisions in general were made by aristocrats.
Moreover,
the law was interpreted,
spoken,
and to the agreed to a degree.
It had to be enforced by the aristocrats working through a council in their
community.
And these councils might have been elective from within the aristocracy or they
could have been simply the whole aristocracy depending really on the size of the
community because you can't have a council functioning to any useful purpose.
If it gets to be too big,
it just becomes something else.
That's where you start.
That's the dark ages.
Now what we shall see as the polos grows and develops and these changes in the,
uh,
economic situation that I've described are happening,
is that these successful farmers
who will,
as I will be telling you next time,
who also will be the fighting men who fight for their Polis,
uh,
in as infantry men,
when the infantry becomes the critically important part of the army,
these men,
the combination of their independence,
their wealth.
I don't,
when I say wealth,
I don't mean great wealth,
but the fact that they do have wealth,
that they amount to something and their role as soldiers makes them demand a
larger voice in the government of the state and the decisions that affect them
so closely.
And so there will be a whole,
I'm looking ahead now projecting into some topics that we'll explore more
closely later,
but they will be finding different ways to insist on their inclusion and their
results will be different in every state in sometimes the old aristocracy we'll
be able to hold on for a very long time and to suppress any,
a attempt to change things other times.
Uh,
and this will be widespread in certain places and it will be very significant.
The dissatisfied people in the society,
mainly these farmers I'm talking about.
Uh,
we'll get together and perhaps fix on some discontented aristocratic individuals
and most particularly pick some aristocrat who has distinguished himself
typically as a soldier,
as a leader of troops and engage really in what amounts to a kind of a
revolution or at least a coup and bring about a kind of a different kind of a
monarchy,
which the Greeks called a tyranny.
And when these tyrannize take place,
they last for different periods of time.
But when the tyrant is removed,
what follows after that is there was never again in that town,
one man rule of any kind either what is established after the,
the tyranny is an oligarchy.
But notice I didn't say aristocracy and oligarchy just means rule of the few.
But as we shall see,
what changes is,
is no longer the rule of those who,
those few who are born in the right place.
It will be based upon the wealth of those people.
And that means that the newly wealthy or the newly well reasonably well off will
participate in their government.
And the form of government,
which is oligarchy,
will be throughout the classical period,
the most characteristic form of government in Greek city states.
When democracy is invented,
it will have its moment and it will spread and there will be numerous
democracies,
but they will never be the majority of the police.
Your typical Polis will be a kind of uh,
uh,
Hanson farmer outfit where people from that class and up we'll participate in
politics,
will be the governing bodies in their state.
They will be the ones who continue to fight in that infantry that is decisive
for the state.
And they will be the ones who,
uh,
make decisions and the people poorer than they will be excluded.
So it's very important to realize that these family farmers who are successful
do not necessarily lead to democracy.
Indeed,
I want to emphasize again,
it is an unusual outcome when they end up with democracy.
So now we've said something about the economic change and something about the
political change,
and the next hour I'll start with the story of the military change that has so
many significant consequences.
Okay.